the 2023 spooky season is shaping up to
be a phenomenal Fright Fest both on the
big and small screens get out your
calendar apps horror fans we've
collected the Deets on all the tales of
Terror soon headed your way
it's been nearly a decade since the
conjuring arrived in theaters and the
franchise that's grown from the based on
a true story Fright Fest shows no signs
of slowing down in addition to the three
films in the main Conjuring series with
a fourth on the way several spin-off
movies have now developed into
sub-franchises of their own most notably
the evil doll series Annabelle and now
yet another Conjuring offshoot is set to
move into sequel territory in 2023
Warner Brothers will release the nun too
a sequel to The Conjuring 2 spin-off the
nun about The Saga of valak a demonic
spirit that takes the form of a nun as
the official plot synopsis puts it a
priest is murdered an evil is spreading
there's something here
that's not meant to be and when volack's
on the loose who are you gonna call you
call Sister Irene of course played by
Taissa Farmiga she portrayed the heroic
nun in the first film and she's back
again to do battle with the Sinister
Spirit on that note Bonnie Ahrens will
once again play the murderous volack for
a story set in 1950s France plus storm
Reed of the Invisible Man and the last
of us will star as another heroic nun
battling the habit-wearing hell fiend
you can also expect the return of Jonas
bloke as Frenchy the poor farmer who was
possessed in the first film and who will
definitely play a part in valak's
terrifying return The Conjuring the
devil made me do it director Michael
shaves is helming the film and malignant
and Meghan writer akayla Cooper pen the
screenplay Volk will be back just in
time to get us ready for the 2023
Halloween season arriving September 8
2023 with an R rating for violent
content and some Terror
it took five years for director and star
Kenneth Rana to follow up his first
Hercules Perot film murder on the Orient
Express with death on the Nile in 2022.
we won't have to wait nearly as long for
the third installment in the series
which brings together yet another
All-Star ensemble cast in another Agatha
Christie Story the world insists on
destruction yet here
masterpieces are big to order every day
set in the titular Italian city a
hunting in Venice will focus on a
retired Poirot played once again by
Branagh who according to the official
plot synopsis is living in self-imposed
Exile however the detective is invited
to attend a seance and after he arrives
one of the other guests winds up
murdered facing strange possibly
Supernatural occurrences and a number of
potential suspects Perot must summon his
courage and his detective skills yet
again to get to the bottom of the
mystery the trailers for the film lean
heavily on the horror elements of the
story giving us a true haunting Vibe
thanks to low lighting a whirling
phantasmagoria creepy kids and a seance
gun very wrong plus the cast is Once
Again full of big names including Tina
Fey Michelle yeoh Jamie Dornan Kelly
Riley Emma Laird and more a haunting in
Venice materializes on September 15 2023
over the last decade or so through films
like the babysitter love and monsters
and underwater Brian Duffield has
established himself as one of genre
Cinema's most compelling writers with
spontaneous in 2020 he proved he was
just as gifted as a director delivering
one of that Gear's best genre films now
he'll try to do it again with an alien
invasion flick starring the mega
talented Caitlyn Dever of dopesick no
one will save you follows a lonely young
woman who spends most of her time alone
in her childhood home alienated from the
world around her then things get weird
and scary when she starts hearing odd
sounds outside and it turns out to be
actual aliens what follows is a
confrontation for the ages or as
Duffield himself put it on Twitter if
you wanted a movie where a bunch of
Grays try to abduct Caitlyn Dever and
she keeps being like no thank you we
made that movie the film's release date
was announced in July 2023 alongside a
first look photo showcasing Diva and
while we're still waiting for more
details on the film we can't wait to
check it out no one will save you hits
Hulu on September 22nd 2023
like any tried and true horror franchise
the saw series will never stop and in
2023 we'll get the 10th installment
aptly named saw 10. the timeline of the
franchise has always been rather twisty
and this time around we're going back to
very early in the story to examine what
happened when John Kramer was tricked by
some dubious medical scammers as you can
see from that report hypognosis isn't
good
would you agree featuring The Return of
Tobin Bell as jigsaw John Kramer saw X
is set between the events of Saw and saw
2. it follows a desperate Kramer as he
heads to Mexico in order to get his
cancer cured through an experimental
procedure only to find that he's been
scammed according to these scans the
tumor was never removed so with the
remaining months of his life he decides
to round up all the people who conned
him and play a game a very brutal game
full of self-surgery and even more
gruesome Fates the first trailer for the
film arrived in July 2023 and offered
plenty of violent Delights for long time
fans of the franchise along with a very
personal mission for jigsaw himself that
might be just Belle's biggest challenge
yet in the series bringing back saw
veteran Shawnee Smith as Kramer disciple
Amanda young saw 10 hits theaters just
in time for the Halloween season on
September 29 2023.
from Freaky to Fear Street we've gotten
no shortage of fun new riffs on slasher
movies in recent years and totally
killer is now primed to be the latest
dive into that particular sub-genre
directed by nanoshka Khan of always be
my maybe the film promises a wild ride
and a classic slasher tropes with the
added Twist of time travel to dial up
the horror comedy experience Kiernan
shipka of chilling Adventures of Sabrina
stars as Jamie who's constantly ignoring
her mother Julie Bowen's warnings about
the sweet 16 killer a slasher who
terrorized the community decades ago
Jaime thinks it's all in the past but
when the killer returns and targets her
family she finds herself not just
running away from the murderer but
running all the way into the past
trapped in 1987 Jaime is left with no
choice but to team up with the teenage
version of her mother played by Olivia
Holt to defeat the sweet 16 killer once
and for all with a cast that also
includes the likes of Randall Park and
Lachlan Monroe and a premise that plays
like Back to the Future meets Halloween
totally killer feels like it could be
one of the bright spots in a crowded
Halloween scene season of horror
releases so don't miss it the film hits
Prime video on October 6th
after reinvigorating the Halloween
franchise with this 2018 legacy sequel
director David Gordon green is now
turning his attention to the Exorcist
franchise setting the stage for a
Trilogy of films that will build on the
original story of a young girl possessed
by a frightening evil in the first
installment in the new series The
Exorcist believer screen Legend Ellen
bursten will return to play Chris McNeil
the mother of Linda Blair's Reagan
McNeil who was possessed by the evil
Pazuzu in the original movie this time
Chris will be called upon to help two
girls who vanished into the woods and
have come back with a bit of a demon
problem joining burstin in the film is
Hamilton breakout Leslie Odom Jr who
will play the father of one of the newly
possessed girls baby you've been gone
three days the Demonic victims will be
portrayed by Lydia Jewett of Night books
and Olivia Markham of Matilda the
Musical and we can also expect to see
Anne Dowd of the handmaid's tale country
singer and actor Jennifer Nettles
Raphael sabarge of Once Upon a Time
two-time Tony winner Norbert Leo butts
and artist okwi okpokwa silly possible
spoiler alert it also seems Linda Blair
who portrayed Reagan in the original
will be involved in the film somehow
above the line reported that she was
seen on set and is claimed she will
reprise her iconic performance however
the site has also reported that
according to Production Studio bloomhaus
Blair was there simply as an advisor so
it remains to be seen whether or not
Blair will actually appear in the film
either way at this point David
gordon-greens definitely got plenty of
experience revisiting horror classics so
it'll be very interesting to see if he
can do for possession movies what he did
for slashers the film is set to hit
theaters a week earlier than initially
planned October 6 2023
development of a film based on the
immensely popular Five Nights at
Freddy's video game franchise dates back
almost to the launch of the original
game it's bounced around since then for
nearly a decade moving through various
Studios and creative teams and now it's
almost here welcome to Freddy Fazbear's
where fantasy and and fun come to life
just like the video game Five Nights at
Freddy's is set at Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza a rundown Chuck E cheese style
restaurant complete with animatronic
animals led by Freddy Fazbear himself at
night these animals shockingly come to
life turning homicidal and threatening
any humans who were unfortunate enough
to be near them in this case that
security guard Mike Schmidt played by
Josh Hutcherson who just took a job at
Freddy's as well as his little sister
Abby played by Piper Rubio as the night
on furos both will find themselves in a
fight for survival as the Monstrous
robots start prowling around the pizza
joint joining Hutcherson and Rubio will
see the likes of Matthew Lillard
Elizabeth lale Mary Stuart Masterson and
YouTuber Corey Kenshin the trailers for
the film feel like they were pulled
directly from the games with character
designs and environments that match the
vibe that made the franchise so popular
in the first place right down to a scary
time in a ball pit that's thanks in part
to the input of Scott cawthon The Game's
Creator who's on board as both producer
and co-writer Jason Bloom also produces
and the film was directed and Co written
by Emma Tammy of the wind Five Nights at
Freddy's hits theaters and the streaming
service peacock on October 27 2023 just
in time for Halloween
more than a decade ago Quentin Tarantino
and Robert Rodriguez teamed up for the
double feature experiment Grindhouse and
in the process they drafted several
genre filmmakers to create fake trailers
to run before and between the films of
these trailers the most popular was Eli
Roth's fake slasher movie Thanksgiving a
concept so enduring that in 2023 it's
finally getting the full-length movie
treatment this holiday season
scared out of here
[Music]
just like the trailer it appears that
Thanksgiving will follow the residents
of a Massachusetts town as they
celebrate the titular holiday complete
with Pilgrim Recreations turkeys and all
the trimmings unfortunately for them a
serial killer is also stalking the town
and he's ready to carve up much more
than a bird this turkey day starring
Tick-Tock star Addison Ray Patrick
Dempsey Gina Gershon and more
Thanksgiving will slice its way into
theaters just in time for the holiday on
November 17 2023.
after 11 Seasons The Walking Dead
finally concluded its run in 2022. the
show premiered in 2010 becoming one of
the most popular television dramas of
the decade it could be microbial viral
parasitic fungal or the wrath of God
there's that sadly its viewership waned
in its later Seasons particularly after
the departure of longtime cast members
like Andrew Lincoln Stephen young and
deny Guerrera however even before The
Walking Dead ended AMC debuted two
spin-off series that explored other
characters in its Universe such as Fear
The Walking Dead and the Anthology
series Tales of The Walking Dead the
latter of which premiered in 2022
however fans of The Walking Dead
characters don't need to worry about
saying goodbye in 2023 AMC has debuted
or plans to debut several spin-off
series and TV movies centered on iconic
characters from the franchise in June
The Walking Dead dead City had its
premiere on AMC plus following the
adventures of Jeffrey Dean Morgan's
Infamous Negan alongside Lauren cohan's
Maggie after the events of the original
series two more spin-offs are on the way
as well The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon a
series that obviously centers on Norman
Reedus's crossbow wielding character
Daryl Dixon premieres on September 10
2023 the other The Walking Dead the ones
who live a mini-series focusing on
departed character is Rick and Michonne
with Andrew Lincoln and deny Guerrero
reprising their roles is set to arrive
sometime in 2024. the Walking Dead fans
will have lots to look forward to in
2023 and Beyond Carol
yeah
yeah you deserve a happy ending too if
there's anything to be learned from
House of the Dragon it's that audiences
are still hungry for more time with
their favorite TV universes
American Horror Story always swings for
the fences with its cinematography
costuming and set design making it
instantly recognizable the latest
season-long storyline American Horror
Story delicate is based on Daniel
Valentine's horror novel delicate
condition and looks like a super creepy
tale about trauma pregnancy and loss
American Horror Story delicate tells the
story of an actress named Anna Alcott
played by AHS regular Emma Roberts who
worries that someone close to her is
preventing her from getting pregnant she
starts in vitro fertilization treatments
gets pregnant and later has a
miscarriage however she believes
something is still growing inside her
body in true AHS fashion it's probably
something terrifying other series
regulars whom we know are returning for
delicate include Dennis O'Hare Billy
Lord and Zachary Quinto the other top
build cast members are Cara Delevingne
and Kim Kardashian both of whom are
making their debut on the series
delicate will also be broken into two
parts due to the labor strikes in
Hollywood part 1 includes five episodes
which will Air weekly starting September
20th part 2 is expected sometime in 2024
director and horror TV Creator Mike
Flanagan typically doesn't miss not only
has he directed some Twisted movies over
the years but he's also given us some of
Netflix's best horror programming The
Haunting of Hill House The Haunting of
blind Manor midnight mass and the
Midnight Club have all been well
received hits for the streaming Giant
and Flanagan will now add some scares to
2023 spooky season with the Fall of the
House of Usher The Fall of the House of
Usher is a modern day amalgamation of
several of the works of Edgar Allan Poe
it focuses on a pharmaceutical CEO who
grows increasingly paranoid as his
children begin to die by progressively
bizarre and violent means Flanagan has
always had a Deft hand when it comes to
building dread so pose Timeless Tales of
Terror seem like a perfect fit for the
director getting to the heart
that's the tricky part Flanagan tends to
work with a reliable stable of actors
and many of them appear in The Fall of
the House of Usher look for Carla Gugino
Kate Siegel Henry Thomas Rahul Kohli and
many more familiar faces in the cast
list other big names include Willa
Fitzgerald Bruce Greenwood Mary McDonald
and Mark Hamill the series arrives on
Netflix on October 12th
Apple TV knows that audiences want
spooky shows during the fall and they
are bringing it with the changeling this
is not the same story as the 1980 horror
film The Changeling nor is it the same
story as the 2008 film starring Angelina
Jolie instead this series is based on a
2017 fantasy horror novel by Victor
Lavale and it looks wholly unnerving the
changeling star's lakeith Stanfield is a
man named Apollo who finally marries the
woman of his dreams played by Clark Bako
and has a child with her however his
world quickly unravels when he wakes up
one morning to find his wife and
daughter have disappeared Without a
Trace they told me not to go but
I didn't listen as he frantically
searches for them Apollo begins to
question the nature of his entire
reality and Supernatural events and
magical beings begin to make him realize
that he may be toying with forces well
beyond his control the first three
episodes of the changeling premiere on
Apple TV on September 8th followed by a
new episode each week thereafter
the Castlevania animated series didn't
seem like it would amount to much when
it was announced but it didn't take long
for audiences to take notice not only
did it do an excellent job of adapting
story Beats from the popular video game
series but it also featured great
writing Stellar voice acting and
incredible animation Four Seasons in and
Netflix has decided to start telling a
different Tale in the same universe with
Castlevania Nocturne whereas Castlevania
focused its attention on Trevor Belmont
Castlevania Nocturne will change up
settings characters and time periods it
will feature Richter Belmont a
descendant of Trevor and will take place
during the French Revolution there have
not been many details released about the
plot just yet but we do know that
Richter will need to find a group of
allies to help him in a battle against
the forces of Darkness gruesome fight
scenes difficult choices and
over-the-top villains will surely abound
the vampire Messiah will come whether
castlevanian Nocturne can keep the magic
going is yet to be seen But judging from
the quality of the original series we
wouldn't bet against it it premieres on
Netflix on September 28th